let me share this one story about the
top Russian official warns of global
tragedy if allies send Ukraine new
weapons this story is on January 22nd
it's page seven if you want to go to it
the story's on page seven and it's
interesting what just happened yesterday
so a leading official in Russia
Parliament has warned of a global
tragedy if Ukraine gets new weapons from
allies as the bitter fight between the
two Nations near the 11th month Mark uh
volodean speaker of State Duma Russia's
lower House of the country's Parliament
issued the ominous message Sunday he
said supplies of offensive weapons to
Kiev issue a regime would lead to a
global catastrophe a global catastrophe
only means the n-word nuclear right he
claimed the United States and NATO's
assistance to Ukraine has led to a
terrible war voladen is a closer Ally of
Vladimir Putin he also is a member of
Putin's Security Council he said if
Washington and NATO Supply weapons that
would be used for striking peaceful City
and making attempt to seize our
territory as they threatened to do it
would trigger retaliation with more
powerful weapons so what does U.S do
yesterday how many tanks did we give to
Ukraine yesterday I think we gave him 31
tanks if I'm not mistaken 31 Abram tanks
if I'm not mistaken was given to them
yesterday I think the number is 31. can
you zoom in a little bit you're correct
there you go the U.S will send 31
powerful battle tanks to Ukraine joining
Germany and sending the vehicles to
support the fight against Russia's
Invasion the decision to deliver the M1
Abram
Abrams Tanks was announced just hours
after Germany said he would send 14 of
its leopard two tanks to the battlefield
Berlin also cleared the way for the
European countries to send german-made
tanks from their own stocks Ukraine has
lobbied Western allies to send military
equipment for months there you go so
yeah here's the other part let me just
say this anytime I want to get your
thoughts on this Russia
this is more to Russia than anything
else
you you this this whole thing if they do
this it's going to be catastrophic if
they do this it's going to be
catastrophic Russia's been saying this
now seven times six or seven times and
they've done nothing okay catastrophic
you know what they're saying to you
Russia No One Believes you anymore they
don't think you're gonna do [__] they
don't think you can do nothing now thank
God some people who are listening to
this Russia doesn't listen to this
podcast Putin's not sitting there saying
let me see what they're going to be
saying on the pbd podcast okay because
if he did hear this on the podcast he
says oh yeah oh yeah boom right
retaliate but the truth of the matter is
you can't threaten somebody six or seven
times and not follow through and the
other side says yeah whatever here's 31
more tanks yeah whatever here's this Tom
what are your thoughts well I think the
sooner that this thing gets resolved uh
the sooner the West can start picking up
the trillion dollar tab it's going to
take to rebuild Ukraine because it's the
breadbasket of Europe it's a huge
manufacturing base and there's a huge
rebuild that's necessary but I'm agree
with you this feels like the mother that
says one more your kids having a tantrum
on the floor and Target one more time
Jeremy no ice cream one more time Jeremy
no jelly beans and then it's like hey
I'll give you a gum if you'll stop right
so I I think I'm I'm kind of kind of
over it just like you are because I just
think that I could do something or just
stop saying it that's exactly right and
I think what the West remember the West
was reluctant a year ago to send Stinger
missiles little stuff yeah now we're
sending 31 of the most advanced battle
tank which will more than meet up
against those leopard two tanks this so
um Germany's leopard two tanks and the
Abrams together are going to over match
uh the Russian side and I think what you
have here is I think the West is
possibly coming to this point of you
know the sacramentalism doesn't work
writing big checks and doing all this
incrementalism doesn't work let's just
send the big stuff in there and let's
get this thing over with because
remember when Russia was brought to its
knees what 30 years ago 35 years ago in
Afghanistan if you've ever seen the
movie Charlie Wilson's War you know what
I'm talking about they have eventually
turned tail and go home and you just it
takes overwhelming force and I don't
think they're going to do anything and I
think it's a very real question is is is
Vladimir really healthy right I think
that's a very real question that's a
different question the question here is
11 months you're not making progress
you're not coming across as the winner
you're not imposing yourself they're not
intimidated you're turning their leader
into a hero he's looking he's being
promoted as the next Churchill being
bullied by a guy like you you're being
compared to a guy that used to live in
Germany who took his own life some say
uh you know you're not this is not a
good storyline for them okay your people
are leaving your country you were the
number two country in the world for
immigrants Russia was number two believe
it or not for a number but they're 11
million number one is U.S at 41 million
Russia is number two you can pull up the
data if you want to pull it up top
countries in the world in Immigration
you've been losing immigrants that are
leaving your place this is not a good
look for you okay
uh this is not a good look for you and
it's hurting you so what are you gonna
do now zoom in okay used to be Russian
house Germany okay so Germany's two
Saudis three Russia's four that's not
even close the US is running loud to
everyone just so you know that number
two years ago in 2019 Russia was for
because we were at 41 million now
they're four okay there you go you're
declining on the list of immigrants
wanting to go to I wonder why and they
thought and I know we gotta wrap up yeah
they thought that winter you know
Winter's coming with the gas and oil and
everything that you know that Russia
um gives to the world as what they um
export would break the backs of Europe
but Europe is still doubling down
Germany's still sending tanks the EU 100
is behind uh Ukraine it's it's
backfiring like crazy against Russia and
coming down to the bite Administration
bro like this is this this is how to be
in a war without saying you're in a war
okay like that proxy wars whatever ever
it is if I send if I want Pat you all
three of you to go do a drive-by and
shoot up uh Rob's house and I Supply you
the car the guns the ammo and you guys
go and shoot up a bunch of people and
kill a bunch of people guess what
legally was gonna happen me as the
sender of all this [__] you're the you
orchestrated it you started you're
supplying all this [__] you are just as
much as in trouble as they are so we are
at like you said we're not going we're
involved bro we're so involved but but
they'll never say by the administration
will never play yo we're in a war trust
me bro we're in it they're only a few
years ago the Winter Olympics were in
Sochi yeah and we were talking about a
new Russia and a new era remember all
that and remember that was the Winter
Olympics when it didn't snow which was
really inconvenient for the Winter
Olympics but uh you remember that there
was no snow but at that time remember oh
it's a new Russia the Cold War is Over
they're the host of an Olympic games all
these things going on and now and now
look where they are I mean this is this
is pretty pathetic okay so if you
enjoyed this club want to see another
one click here to watch another clip and
if you want to take advantage the latest
gold Signature Series products that just
came out we have a bunch of new merch
that's out this is a color changing mug
when you drink coffee that lion turns
into a real lion and then we have
hoodies with vitamin gold on it the gold
Signature Series hat shirts I'm an
entrepreneur anyways we have a lot of
items they're selling out if you want to
take advantage the gold Signature Series
click here place your order Sports your
right taming gear and tag us with the
hashtag valuetainment
[Music]